when you found out that whack was
working with six nine what was your
original reaction
my original reaction i thought it was
kind of weird
i thought it was like you know it made
me look at him
a different way
but not like
not like a
like a [ __ ] you type well it was just
more like oh okay i didn't know you were
that you know
that type of guy
what type of guy like you know just you
know just oh you know i don't i don't
know maybe i don't know who i i don't
know i don't even know how how that
happened
to be honest with you but
you know just like you know like you're
like oh okay that's like okay yeah like
it was one of those like not like uh oh
he yeah [ __ ] he's weird it was more
like uh oh [ __ ] right like not a bad
like
like get the money by all
by all means
but you know it's just like i think it
threw a lot of people off yeah you know
just kind of like you know it's a big
like
you know
it's definitely uh kind of like uh he's
all he's i know ironic that's very
ironic
it's like it's like that collab of two
people that's just like
oh [ __ ]
um
i know he would he was talking forever
about the possibility of you and six
nine boxing
um
how far down the line did those
conversations go
um that might have been
how they they might have maybe been the
angle right yeah might have been how
they connected because i guess they
might have been in contact trying to
figure out but i never talked to to
signal i wouldn't talk
to him if
he was the last person i had on a jail
call like
you know so i guess maybe that's how
their relationship came about was it uh
as far as the boxing match it got as
deep as
him
making like you know
high demands i guess